one of the secret little joys of having
kids is you get to do kid things again
and kid things are fun it's fun to go
throw a ball around in the park it's fun
to like wrestle on the floor and play
with cars and stuff it's fun to go ride
bikes around the neighborhood it's fun
to go to bouncy castles and eat Happy
Meals and that is a fun thing to do but
it's
weird if you do it without kids not
everyone gets to have kids some people
suffer infertility you can do it with
your nieces and nephews you can do it in
your community and go kind of rough ass
with the kids okay yeah that's kind of
that isn't that fun but if you do it
as an adult
you it's sad
because you
you haven't grown up it's just you can't
you actually can't go back in time